okay so after that was Sweden Sweden was
by far
yeah we we okay here's what I did uh we
got there and I messaged Felix I was
like where do I go because if this is
not from Stockholm but he's from
Gothenburg yeah yeah he was like I was
like is there one spot I gotta go eat
and so he sent me this restaurant he was
like yeah this is where I would go to
eat if I was in Stockholm okay and I
went there and it was insane it was so
good yeah the meatballs right oh my God
oh my God I'm sorry I didn't get to try
them yeah I had two life-changing meals
here uh one was in Denmark and one was
in Sweden
meatballs and hot dogs yeah meatballs
and hot dogs literally you know when you
have one of those meals where you're
like I'm going to remember this meal for
the rest of my life memory unlocked yeah
yeah yeah that happened twice in this
tour I have never personally been a big
like meatballs person
generally they're pretty average for me
yeah but my God these were just these
were just enough yeah they're insane me
and Connor ordered one to share between
menu items they were all pretty good but
the meatballs were just and then dude I
had like a dessert I got like apple pie
best apple pie of my life yeah I had uh
another Glizzy [__] a joke did you
only get [__] hot dogs in McDonald's
and honestly Swedish hot dogs also
girded you try to make this
okay so I'm like in Denmark right where
like you know you have like a shitload
of toppings you can put on it to add
like that much more flavor the Swedish
hot dogs are just like your bog standard
like you know ketchup mustard and you
talk [__] about the Costco fattest
[__] Glizzy I've seen in my life like
this guy was gothy as fun with a tiny
tiny bun really cheap as well
um and yeah it was [__] great loved
it I knew the restaurant was gonna be
good when I walked in and I did not see
a single person under 40 in the
restaurant yeah I just like oh this
seems like a place Felix would go to
yeah
um but yeah I mean it was I will never
forget
it
thank you for showing us this yeah it
was about that yeah
but uh yeah I mean like I'm going to
remember the first time I had a daily
shot dog and now I'm gonna remember the
very first time I had a Swedish meatball
because every time I have a meatball
afterwards I'm going to compare it to
that one and I don't think it's ever
going to match up honestly like it was
like the first time I took him in I was
it just it was just like on that level
of just like a core memory I want to cry
because this meal is so [__] good and
I feel like I'm unlocking new taste buds
now
um yeah it was it was insane yeah I have
nothing bad to say about the meals I had
in Sweden after that actually we should
preface so that we can give ourselves
some kind of out here sure if people
disagree with our takes we should be
like these are based on just the meals
we had yeah the entire Cuisine yes yeah
absolutely um so you know unfortunately
this is gonna be based on pure gatchlock
and whether we went to a good restaurant
or not yeah so if you're from this
country don't be offended yeah versus on
this list I'm sure yeah everyone get
ready so all right was Oslo Norway uh
which uh I booked a me and gone a nice
restaurant for lunch and it's pretty
good yeah uh it was it was like how do I
describe it it tasted very healthy is
what I always say what did you get it
was like a sharing experience or
something like yes and they bought some
veal we had speech yeah that was amazing
yeah we had like red beats on uh or with
some special sauce like sauce and some
onions and it sounds so not exciting but
it was really really good it was the
star of the entire like everything that
we got given yeah we had some it was
like sour cream with some really nice
flat bread yeah uh and uh cauliflower
wings so they were like cauliflower that
were cooked like chicken wings it was a
solid meal I think it was not as good as
Sweden and Denmark but I think it was
better for me than Ireland and
Netherlands I think I'd put it a
basically yeah I wouldn't disagree with
that unless you think B yeah I think B
you think B yeah
honestly if it was up to me I would read
Netherlands a like I thought it was less
impressive than their croissant oh my
gosh the uh
no you had noodles
did I have noodles we had noodles oh
yeah that was that wasn't the show
though yeah that was in the show I don't
really count that one no see but that's
the problem right is that this was like
right in the middle of that six show
like streak and so we were constantly
just on this like grind of like okay you
know if I can get to the destination
immediately start go you know go to The
Venue try and walk around for a little
bit to see at least a little bit of the
city and then if you have time you might
have see this this is where the
difference in priority lies Joe you just
wanted to explore like the city and
stuff me and Conor are like all right we
need a good meal where we want to try
the local Cuisine I I clown on the
French but I think there's one part of
me that is French and it's the fact that
no matter where I went I was like I want
a [__] three-course meal I was like I
got one hour we can make it work yeah
yeah I just wanted to see the city I was
like what's the highest rated restaurant
that's near walking distance and is also
part of the local Cuisine all right
we're going there we're going there that
was that was my experience country yeah
pretty much would squeeze in uh a lunch
like meal because I thought in my head
the way that I judge if I want to come
back to a country is like do I have did
I have like amazing restaurant
experiences because that then makes me
think oh there's so much good food that
I can get excited for right so I really
wanted to just try some really good food
in each country so that I could think
okay when I come back I know that
there's like at least one good place
that I like and that I'm sure there's
reflect of The Culinary experience yeah
I think this really shows like our
differences in how we treat like
visiting a place because like I'm much
more focused on like sightseeing and
just like yeah getting the vibe of the
actual like City or wherever I am and
like the food is for me is kind of just
like optional nah that's like the stuff
sightseeing I need a nice meal at the
end of the sightseeing I feel like it's
like when people go to Japan and they're
like oh yeah I'm just gonna eat the
family malt sandwiches I'm like at least
get the onigiri
like come on man like at least try yeah
yeah uh okay so what you guys both think
B then okay I'd like if it up to me uh
Netherlands would be a and uh
I'm gonna say oh man okay well
okay okay how should we do this maybe on
the record I'm saying Norway's a but
fine we can put it in B yeah we'll put
no a n b yeah
um all right all right leads Germany to
Germany Berlin
um the [__] Venus schnitzel I had was
so good it wasn't really that good I I
really liked it but then again I'm a
sucker for Venus schnitzel I'm also easy
to please with German food so yeah all
right so I gotta say I really really
[__] enjoyed the Germany show I
really felt like for once I connected
with the Germans you know like how so I
I was just like you know what your bread
actually [__] goaded I felt like I
felt like I was on a news character Arc
and uh I got a really good reception at
the German show which I was surprising
to me it felt like it felt like uh you
know when you fight the public mask and
we were in town yeah yeah yeah I felt
like uh what's the word I'm looking for
uh not Rehabilitation but uh
what's Rehabilitation yeah it was kind
of Rehabilitation
was they gave his uh yeah me a standing
ovation when I said bread is good I was
I was small I was like very easy yeah
I know Redemption it felt like you know
I had a little Redemption Arc to the
Germans which uh pains me to say that
I'm about to make an enemy of the
Germans again no uh because I I just
started my I just had a Redemption Arc
uh and I gotta say uh so I didn't just
spend a day in Berlin it's been like
five days in cologne as well trying as
much German cuisine as I could sure
I think British Cuisine is better oh I I
know I I think British Cuisine is better
than German cuisine I I genuinely I wait
did you say that on the Germany show no
yeah you would have been murdered
before I judge you uh what are your
reasonings what are my reasoning so a
lot of dishes kind of feel similar to
like to like British like British
Cuisine uh and when I had like a German
like dish something like schnitzel for
example I would just I was just like I'd
rather have fish and chips you know I
I'd rather have like a good fish and
chips the Schnitzel was fine it was fine
I'd rather fish and chips you know um
that's fair I think Germany I I like it
and I like the food Dominic's I'm just
I'm blinded by the bread and the like I
just depressed okay so for when I say
Cuisine you guys beat us in beer and
bread that's not even that's not even a
[__] argument but in just like the
dishes that traditional German dishes
that you had I was just like you know
what I think I think there are more
there's more in a British Cuisine you
know I think a lot of people clown on
British Cuisine and I've had enough
because uh now that I've been abroad I'm
like you know what I actually think I
like British food more as well I mean I
think on average yes yes
I think just because I like so many
meals in Germany I'll get thing I'll get
like a dish yeah and I'll only like the
main part of the Dish everything around
it I'm like I don't really I don't
really care I mean I had a curry worse
and it was probably the worst Curry
worst I've had in Germany I've had I had
two curry wests in Germany and I'm like
this
this is your this is your strongest
Curry this is your this is this this is
your strongest fighter really I'm also
not a fan of like boiled potatoes and
there's so many times you get boiled
potatoes and stuff yeah all potatoes is
in the UK as well not often we normally
get the chips we have roasted potatoes
potatoes I love the crisp fluffy you
have the groceries outside you got the
rose memory and the land of fluffy
inside as well that being said that
that's like I did I think it was
probably the weakest meal of the tour we
had because I think we just didn't we
didn't go like to the best spot we went
to a beer garden and I felt like it was
just overly touristy and it was just I I
I don't think it was like great food I
liked it
the beer was great though I mean it was
great the video was great the beer was
great and it was it was like the Berlin
beer which is like one of the I think
worst ones and it was still it was still
pretty yeah the weakest beer was still
better than any beers you can get in
England they feel like they they put all
the points in bread and beer which are
essentially just different forms of each
other yeah dude don't get me wrong I
could live off bread and beer that's
like half the best diet I know you could
not and I'd be I'd be very happy but I
think on average like I would I mean
what even is British British food is so
[__] weird British food is not even a
food anymore it's like well that's why
I'm [__] racial the fact you guys
rate that higher than the Germans I
think British food is a thing it's like
a combination of like a lot of things I
think uh it's very like one thing people
think British food they think like
[__] fish and chips uh what else do
you think anything food actually from
from someone not from England what do
you think when do you think British food
uh fish and chips toast sandwich toast
sandwich uh beans okay actually beans
are golden all right that's that's not a
[__] talk the beans here
look at the beans this is just the first
three things
are American tour manager came to the UK
and they had an English breakfast and
um she showed us I was like can I see a
picture of it and the sausage looked
mummified it looked like it had been
dried for years yeah and the I think
they had like eggs that looked awful it
just looked terrible it's good I was
like this looks [__] horrible yeah it
was a nightmare see it's easy to just
post a picture of like a shitty British
me and be like ah the British have no
taste but you know I I think and you
know now that you know traveling around
I really rate our [__] pasties and I
think our Savory pastries to be fair yes
I do read that [__] anything you can
get in Greg's man
how did we talk how does that always
happen we talk about Germany it comes
back to the UK let's
Island Amsterdam and Norway were better
than Germany the meals we had yeah I
don't [__] remember anything I had in
Amsterdam nowhere I went to the dolls
it's your fault that is your fault all
right so what Cod guys uh are we gonna
put anything in D because I I don't
think I have anything else that would
guarantee no I'll put it C then oh yeah
I'll put it I can't believe he's not
being used is it yeah I guess these not
being used I did feel wrong to put
something in detail put Germany in deep
no Deutschland
put UK in Celsius
uh which I mean I I had one of the I had
an amazing Curry the other night in
London that was great yeah I did
I did a really good at expanding day we
sometimes use the spices that we stole
yeah you know that's that's one thing
yeah I think I I honestly I I always
have feel like I enjoy my meals in the
UK
I honestly think that the quality of a
lot okay it's very different though
actually London is different
um but you know I generally think the
quality of food in England has just gone
up uh as time's gone by I Just Disagree
that Irish food was better than than
stuff in London okay yeah actually I
just can't actually I agree this is why
I said Island should go and see you
can't believe me okay yeah yeah you're
right I was I had Guinness on my mind
I just I just wanted to put Guinness on
there let's be honest but yeah I think
that
okay I'm gonna now make a enemy of the
Irish uh I think UK food was better than
the Ireland food as well okay
don't look at me like that Joe what did
you eat what did you eat in Ireland I
know what you want what I eat in Ireland
yeah what I what tell me yeah
okay to be fair you recommended me like
the new uh so I've had Greg's once
before this and it was I just had like a
sausage roll
um which is fine which is fine it's good
uh but the one you recommended yeah the
[__] beans cheese and sausage pasty
was it that's the one yeah yeah that was
bomb yeah
um so where's the UK going I think it's
going Hi-C I think it's I don't think
it's on the same level as other European
countries right now but if we're taking
on the Germans and the Irish uh I think
we're better I I think we're better and
I'm sticking with that and I don't care
if that's the hot take of the day okay
but I think UK I think UK food should uh
it's it's not a high tier Cuisine I'm
not gonna call it that but it's
definitely not as low as the entire
world says it is you know you think you
know we've got Sunday roasts we got
[__] um afternoon tea as well also
like I think full English breakfast
pasties yeah we've got good sausages
here that's the one yeah I I think it's
it's way better than people giving
credit for I've turned around and see
I've I've never been to India but out of
all the places where I've had Indian
food the UK is normally my favorite
place to have it
I mean that's just like could be a bad
take yes that's fine I think low B you
think low bounce
is known for having no foods normally
well yeah the producers here are
probably pretty pretty vocal about their
feelings on it uh to be fair the burger
I had was pretty [__] list
food no well it's food whilst food
really struggles to find an identity I
think
um
it's sheep uh well lamb uh leek uh and
cakes typically none of which you had
guys
um mainly because you're in Cardiff and
Cardiff is like the least Welsh place in
Wales right
um it really did just feel like England
2.0 Yeah well yeah Cardiff is just an
extensioners because it's so close to
England and it's also a major city and
historical reasons but uh I think I mean
honestly I don't even think we had a
burger we had a burger
foreign
I mean I think I it was about the same
as Irish or maybe less than Irish food I
think it the Germans would be so pissed
off to have it higher but I think it's
yeah I mean let's piss off the Germans
higher than D or ID or low [__]
[__] the Germans oh my God so yeah I
would admit I was wrong about your bread
but I'm sticking with this new tank I
have British Cuisine yeah
uh solos German cuisine
that's so unbelievably cap I couldn't
believe what you just said oh my God